anything else
i have nothing to hide from me maybe
but have you told the girl the truth
that witches obtain children so they can
feed them with magic herbs the few who
survive become witches themselves all
human feelings and reactions are trained
out of them
they are turned into monsters to kill
other monsters that's not going to
happen to her but it happened to you
for better or worse
she's with you now
how does she feel about it
oh
the look of a man who's worried he's
lost his touch
the look of a man who's wondering why
his old friend is cheating
you got me there
magic knives
by the gate if any other me leaves this
place
right for your life what's happening
there's a brookshire in the house
oh what
what are you doing
what's going on geralt
now
[Music]
uh
um
greater
middling
it's all the same
something out there waits for you
something more oh fun
there is no more hiding from milfgirl
he is your destiny
i need to understand some things
you claim the law of surprise and got me
why slay this beast
i saved your father's life
what exactly is cameron
you're home
finally
embroidery here so she'd be safe
to protect her it's hard to do when i
don't know who i'm protecting
or what i'm protecting her from
you spend a lifetime alone
what changed you
you know for a finger work
i want to be powerful
do you have what it takes
i dream
of becoming important to someone you're
important to me
and this
is your legacy
to save this paper
this continent
you're in chains behind enemy lines the
emperor
do you really think offering me as a
sacrifice will despair your failure
we're blind the war's just begun
[Music]
humans do bad things to everybody
monsters
and this horrid looks close in teeth
monsters are born of deeds done
unforgivable ones
welcome back everyone toss a coin to
your witcher they just dropped a whole
bunch of footage from the witcher season
2 episode 1 in longer trailer footage
from a later episode so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes i will be doing videos for
the witcher season 2 just like i did for
season 1 and they just confirmed that
they renewed the show for the witcher
season 3 although technically if you've
been watching my videos we actually got
news about that like last year like a
long time ago they also announced that
they're doing another anime movie like
the nightmare of the wolf it was
actually really solid backstory about
vesemir how he grew up and became a
witcher then the story of the giant
attack on camera and why it got sacked
and why they can't create witchers
anymore sort of telling you that before
season two as you probably guessed the
reason why they dropped that before
season two is because we're going to
care marin as siri begins to train as a
witcher and they learn more about her
power but a lot of the footage here and
i'll just go through shot by shot
talking about the episode one scenes and
then the other trailer footage most of
this is all from early on in season two
episode one when they've gone to
novella's mansion so all this is from a
grain of truth in the books and is a
short story that takes place before the
events of blood of elves which is what
they're using for most of the plot of
season 2 because that's just the next
book in the series so there's just the
next part of the story that they're
telling but because they skipped over
some of the early short stories they're
just jumping back and doing a grain of
truth so in the books the events of this
story take place way earlier in the
timeline and siri was not there for
what's going on but they've changed that
for the tv show so if you're not
familiar with the grain of truth i think
i've talked about this a little bit in
my earlier videos is that it's basically
a darker version of the beauty and the
beast story where you have the beast
novella on who he's talking to here he's
being played by christopher heiju who
played tormund giantsbane during game of
thrones you might be able to detect his
voice there but he's kind of
unrecognizable underneath those
prosthetics in the makeup the knives
that they're throwing at the picture
there that's a picture of what he looked
like before he turned into the beast
before he got cursed just like beauty
and the beast he did something terrible
to get his curse and in the witcher
universe navellan definitely deserves
his curse he's very remorseful about
what he did it involves him and some of
his former comrades doing something
really really terrible to a young woman
so he definitely earned the curse but
the reason why the short story in the
episode is titled a grain of truth is
because this whole idea of geralt not
fully understanding what the dynamic is
here with the beauty and the beast
scenario that's playing out he kind of
comes to the wrong conclusion initially
until he finds out what's really
happening so in this first season two
episode one clip you just see him having
a drink joking as if he's been friends
with the villain for a long time you
just get a feel for his character he
seems like a genuinely decent guy it's
not quite like beast from beauty and the
beast but in the second clip they're
still inside neville's mansion it's just
later in the evening and here's this big
scream in the background so he takes his
witcher potions and he's going out to
fight what he thinks is going to be a
monster that's what he's telling siri
here like stay here don't do anything
also because they're kind of afraid of
serious power as well so he's trying to
protect her but also protect her from
her power if you want to make a marvel
mcu comparison she's kind of like a
scarlet witch type of character someone
who's crazy op but they don't fully
understand how her powers work and she
herself doesn't fully understand how her
powers work yet so usually when she
opens up there's a lot of collateral
damage but geralt is basically just
yelling at her while i go deal with this
monster and the monster you're hearing
in the background is actually the beauty
from this beauty in the beast storyline
the dark beauty and the beast storyline
it's neveland's lover verena who geralt
thinks is secretly feeding off of
novellan without his knowledge but then
finds out that that's not the case
they're actually living in a really
crazy codependent relationship so they
actually do love each other and this is
really sad dark ending to the episode
then we got our first look at kim bonya
is the live-action version of vesamir a
lot of people just wondering what it was
going to look like i think it's actually
going to be pretty decent you may
remember him from killing eve henry
cavill said a lot of good things about
his scenes with him so i'm really
looking forward to some geralt and
vesemir scenes but this is vesamir
meeting siri for the first time if you
played the video games you actually saw
them after they'd been together and he'd
been training siri for a long time after
he become old uncle vesemir so we're
gonna watch that slowly play out over
the course of season two it seems like
vesimir and the other witchers who are
here when girl brings siri in cohen
eskel and lambert are all kind of wary
of siri once geralt explains what's
going on with her once they start to
learn about her elder blood powers we
see more of serious witcher training
there's a little bit of yennefer at the
beginning of season two remember she got
captured by the forces of nilfgaard so
she'll be forced to serve emperor mir
for a little while but eventually she
will be reunited with geralt and siri
and even though there isn't a bunch of
yaskir footage he is going to be in
season two it's just that in the book
story that they're doing for the first
couple of episodes none of them are all
together it's really just geralt and
siri then yaskir is off by himself
somewhere else and jennifer's off in
nilfgaard also by herself they kind of
intercut this with a lot of footage from
season one so you get a couple shots
from season two but if you spotted any
big easter eggs or any big scenes in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the
comments and i'll try to cover it in the
comments i just try to do a quick
reaction video here because there's so
much new footage netflix kind of did
their big comic con event today so
that's why there's so many trailers
dropping i just did that new stranger
things season 4 trailer video you can
click here for that and click here for
my brand new eternals trailer video for
kit harrington's black knight character
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your
witcher